today on our show man Dom I don't warn
the stone that's my Star Wars Star Wars
horse is awakening cats we're talking
about right here today I'm Batman I'm
Batman welcome back kids welcome to fat
man I'm Batman Kevin Smith mark barnard
okay big time important stuff going on
you know what today is we'll get to in a
second man all right we can't bury the
lede sports awakens day
it's all happening manage the forces
awakened all over our face neck and
chest all right here's the thing man yo
star we're taping this before Star Wars
has happened yes but Star Wars is
happening and we're gonna see it I'm not
gonna be here I'm as I said I'm in
Boulder Marc I don't know where Mark is
I'm gonna be here there you go so I'm
holding it down we're gonna be seeing it
in two different places man but we're
gonna be able to still give you our
reviews right here because present Kevin
mark are gonna hand off to future Kevin
mark and that crazy that's the power of
YouTube you can reach in the future like
eobard thawne and [ __ ] like that deep
cuts anyway mm-hmm right now let's find
out man I'm excited I'm excited I don't
know about you guys but I'm excited to
find out what Kevin Smith has to hear
say about the Star Wars The Force
awakens by the way I think what do I
think what is Mark van Arden thing we
don't even know and we're about to find
out right now so without further ado man
we reach into the future and find out
what future Kevin future Mark found out
of what they stay what we think I'm Star
Wars The Force awakens Hey
and hopefully we haven't died yet yeah
oh my all that be creep what are you
like if we tell you be tossed if you
should have a picture mark of you guys
there's a card comes up soon they die
there's a circus accident people that
dampen anybody hopefully
we should look into the future this is
wrong right what if we find something we
have too much power
no one mansion is much fun we used to
know that by doing this we're tampering
with the fuse we totally are but get a
butter flare paradise isn't do it do
what we need to do is ask our future
selves for [ __ ] sports Almanac
then we're gonna on a casino hey future
us look out for us would you yeah
[ __ ] we're doing a free show on
YouTube give us the sports Almanac I'd
better stop we'll buy a TV channel and
do the [ __ ] there 24/7 like CNN for
nerds oh here we go
handing off to future cab and future
mark with their review of the force
awakens hey so it's 1:40 a.m. I am in
the parking lot fish from the theater I
just saw the force awakens my feelings
about it are still a little raw
definitely not processed in any way but
you know like I I haven't got to the
point where I can almost like I can
figure out the stuff that I didn't like
other stuff that I that I loved um
I mean there's the big thing that
happens at the end that that I am
absolutely not going to spoil for
anybody but I sort of wish that it I
sort of wish that it wasn't quite I wish
that it mattered more you know in a way
to the story itself to the to the events
itself as opposed to just being a thing
that happens and you know I did I would
talk more about it if I felt like I
could without ruining it for somebody at
some point and this is absolutely a
thing that you don't want ruined and if
in ruins for you should just
excommunicate them from your lives you
know there's there's there's a detour to
that the movie takes in the middle that
felt a little not not wasted per se just
like a place to go because we needed a
place to go but you know like at the end
of the day the thing the thing that I
loved
star wars movies is the way they make
you feel and there are moments in this
movie that make me feel absolutely like
I'm 10 years old again um you know like
it feels like a Star Wars movie and the
way that none of the prequels did in a
way that even Return of the Jedi kind of
didn't um but yeah you'll you'll have to
forgive me because I am a little it is
as I said 140 in the morning I just came
out of the movie theater I'm hopped up
on cold meds and and and and booze a
flag coffee and just kind of emotionally
spent from the fact that I saw Star Wars
movie again a real Star Wars movie for
the first time in 30 years and again it
it feels like Star Wars and regardless
of whatever happens in it regardless of
you know I'm sure that what I see it
again is I'm going to in a couple of
days I'll be able to get a better read
for myself of the the things that I felt
you know worked it didn't work or some
honest critique of you know the ways
that it's often in the ways that it's
slightly less than awesome but any fears
that I that I might have had that JJ
would JJ no movie fingers I've always
felt that JJ is amazing at beginnings
he's he's absolutely phenomenal at
beginnings you look at any of the way
his TV show start you look at anyway
these movies start you know and we're
not even talking about Star Trek into
darkness because that yeah it's must be
gotten even at this point JJ will say
that um but he does beginning this in a
way that that make you want to stay on
for the ride and this is maybe the first
thing that I've seen him do where the
females are landing as well so yeah I
mean and and and there was not an
overabundance of lens flare which you
know at this point is always a thing to
be thankful for but yeah I'm sure that
that Kevin either has or will chime in
with a slightly more effusive a slightly
more face neck and chest that I'm too
sleepy
and I'm too satisfied to be
overwhelmingly holy [ __ ] did you see
that but uh yeah I'm sure we will talk
about at length more I'm sure that I
will have different feelings later um or
whatever feelings I have now will be
amplified but you know holy I'm yeah you
know [ __ ] before so woken and and I'm
I am right now a happy boy so you know
for uh for me Ngoc Bernard --n 1:45 a.m.
Friday morning after seeing the force
awakens opening night yeah if you
weren't already going to see it you
should go do that because you know nerds
hey pass keV its future keV checking in
from the future man where apparently
everything is as blank as a Beckett play
we're clerks like no set whatsoever man
but doesn't matter cuz what we're
talking about don't require set that's
all they need they literally could have
done that as the movie because JJ could
have shot that for about two hours and
people would have been like I liked it
more than fan of Medicine stuffs but
what I don't want to curse the darkness
I want to light a candle now don't have
to put anyone else down to raise
somebody else up let's talk about this
amazing movie I saw the force awakens
last night and I was like a child a fat
child in the cereal aisle at the food
store just like I can have all of this
like I just ate it all put it everywhere
and stuff it was a beautiful experience
now I'm going to tell you a very spoiler
filled review my thoughts not a review
but really my just thoughts the things
that I wrote down that I could remember
about the movie cuz I didn't want to
write about it while I was sitting there
watching the movie I just took it all in
man so I'm gonna put it right up in
front Street you know some people be
like hey I remember you reviewed the
prequels and you were like Phantom
Menace is just right next to Empire in
that order let's address that let's
dress that before we go further I'm not
backpedaling at all by any stretch of
the imagination but ladies Jenna I
subscribe to the it can't be with the
one you love love the one you with you
know what I'm saying so we weren't
getting any more Star Wars movies that
was the Star Wars movie and it was made
by
starwars master himself George Lucas Oh
uh I you know I was I was fine with them
you know if that was the only Star Wars
you're gonna have that's that's it man
but this force awakens this is the Star
Wars movie we were all hoping for back
then it is absolutely fun it's so
canonical it's crazy man let's dive into
it I just want to put that up front cuz
a lot of people like [ __ ] you you liked
Phantom Menace and stuff like that to be
fair I recently what we watched the
whole prequel trilogy before going to
see this and hikes but in any event
again let's talk about what happened in
this amazing movie man JJ Abrams crushed
it ladies and gentlemen as I said when I
went to visit the set back in the day
and got to walk on the Millennium Falcon
he created the cinematic fountain youth
man he did the impossible he brought the
magic back like he put the star and star
wars man like it is it's a trip down
memory lane like I went into that
theater and came out nine-year old
butterball kid seven year old butterball
cares for some ISIL Star Wars 1977 so
III was there again transported and I'll
tell you how good this movie has to be
to beat the elements by which under
which I saw this movie sat in the front
row I couldn't get any tickling ticks I
got front row in a movie theater with 3d
I didn't want to buy 3d 3d was good but
I'm not 3d guy and stuff so I'm upfront
we're in the 3d glasses and the sound in
the theater was turned down like way
down man it wasn't like right like movie
there's almost down like when you're
watching movie watch like turn it down
I'm sorry asleep and turned down is that
low so I had to listen a bunch those
three elements man make any movie kind
of intolerable didn't matter this movie
was so good transcended the poor
watching experience I had man is not
that poor look I was just happy to see
this thing I'd seen a bunch of it
earlier on but I hadn't seen the whole
movie from end to end and what a delight
it was I got my notes written down right
there so up to constantly be referencing
them over here if I look down that's
what I'm looking at okay so let me just
talk about the elements that I wrote in
order Oscar Isaacs is Poe I like Poe
Dameron I like this character a lot I
like the way he talks like the way Oscar
Isaacs plays him I like that he's got
the swagger behind
solo buddies resistance pilot and stuff
right away we meet him and bb-8 with Max
von Sydow on jakku i
I liked him right away I haven't seen
much of him in the trailers and stuff
but in this performance and you know
spoilers he's again oh [ __ ] thing is
spoilers later Jim he's not in the movie
a mess of it not a ton you know but when
he's in it man he's dynamite I liked him
really liked bb-8 anyone who's like this
is going to be the Jar Jar Binks look
[ __ ] bb-8 wonderful addition to the
universe stormtrooper transport massacre
that opens the movie I'm saying it like
I shouldn't be saying it but again
spoilers and don't watch this if you
haven't seen the movie fascinating man
like how cool to take the perspective of
the Empire the stormtroopers man like
watch them get ready to come down to
this planet like flame it up and stuff
that was dope and I just like the
storyline idea in general of a
stormtrooper who's like I want to do
this anymore is just a deserter man
everyone calls him trails two people in
the trailer and then kylo Ren when the
stormtroopers want to fight some with
the lightsaber spoilers lightsaber
blocker thing he was a traitor and then
the kylo Ren later on he's like traitor
a Doug I like that idea the whole thing
of him just jumping out of the first
order it's not the Empire anymore
led to one of the coolest shots in the
movie man which is like his buddy gets
shot a stormtrooper buddy or just a
stormtrooper and Finn our hero of the
stormtrooper who deserts he goes to aid
him or like you know help him out and
stuff and the guy touches his helmet
with his hand and runs a bloody paw
print handprint over the stormtroopers
white helmet striking image man really
[ __ ] cool when I visited the set JJ
showed me an image of that and I was
like that he said this might be the
poster I was like that'd be amazing his
poster they clearly kept that hidden but
I loved that about a visual man and
never I can't imagine or can remember
ever seeing blood on a stormtrooper Aust
costume helmet in the other movies as a
cool idea and very graphic and also you
know just guys sitting there going I
don't want to be this guy at that image
blood on his uniform stuff his dead
buddies blood I'll certainly send a guy
out the first order man and that's we
learn that these storms
they're not clones they've been trained
by the first order raised taken since
they were children and conditioned so
they're not clones but that's how you
get a storyline where the guys like I'm
gonna get out of here it's no clone
could quit you know to the stormtroopers
he's a clone this guy not and he's no
clone so he quit men and boom Finn is
off on the adventure and and let's see
what do I got next the max Vaughn see
down saying general talking about like
Poe Dameron goes like oh you know
general Organa and Max when Sita's
character goes general he's like what
did he sat ready to me she's royalty and
oh my god she was a princess that's what
he means that my look is bang it's taken
out by kylo Ren is pretty vicious right
away and let's jump to kylo Ren I like
this character a lot man I dig it like I
dig his kind of emo takes out my
spoilers when he takes his helmet off
man he's all clean and beautiful like
that one dr. doom storyline we took the
mask off here one little cut here and
stuff good news is throughout the movie
particularly by the end of the movie he
gets [ __ ] up and he's on the way to
Vader the guy he wants so badly to be
man but first we meet him on jakku he's
badass man I love that his voice
delivery is down here it's not all arch
and everything's just pretty calm just
like you know I'm gonna I'm gonna kill
the Jedi and know through that mask I'm
gonna kill the Jetta awesome
introduction awesome seeing that
character awesome seeing that whole
sequence man that the first order comes
in like they give the order like kill
all the villagers and captain phasma's
like on my command and a lady
stormtrooper man it's silver but they
start blasting killing people for no
good reason man or you know they're good
reasons but they ain't good reasons and
stuff the bad people it's very clear in
this movie remember the prequels we're
really who's bad guys the politics is
that guy I don't understand what's going
on very clear in this movie who the bad
guys and the good guys are and that's
very helpful
because you know let's be honest at the
hearts kids movie I was a wonderful
thing sitting in the theater and
watching generations watch this flick
man I talk to people like I'm bringing
my dad he's 65 but he took me to see
Star Wars that make me cry I saw people
in the theater is 11:45 with their kids
man like families is like this is a
multi generations it's not just a movie
this is a pop cultural phenomenon that's
Spain
ends generations movies going to make a
[ __ ] fortune anyway back to the movie
itself kylo Ren stopping a laser blast
in midair we've never seen that in a
movie before using the force to be like
sure and the laser just sits there and
then at the end of scene we walks away
shooting it finally hit aah that was
badass let's be honest man
let's see Poe and Finn and the TIE
fighter escape oh I love this sequence
man they meet each other for the first
time become buddies and thin breaks them
out what looks like a Death Star and
stuff like that but it's Imperial
starship they get it they get out
through a TIE fighter and as somebody
who's grown up watching these movies it
was wonderful because it's one of those
things real like I've always wanted to
see a TIE fighter do that look at look
how much time you're spending in the TIE
fighter man and they had two people in
the TIE fighter this time and they're
both taking all that they try to get off
the starship they're tethered and all
the star troopers start shooting them
they start shooting back love that
sequence man then they get blasted out
of the air spoilers they get blasted out
of the air they kind of win but like it
shows off-post skills as a pilot the
comradery between those two characters
Finn and Poe and then takes us right
back to jakku this movie was a lot like
Mad Max and as much as Mad Max like
we're going here we're going here now
we're going back there the same place
same thing here is like we're on jakku
we're off to cool we go back to jakku
and stuff and then once they get off -
good as they're they don't go back so
let me see what's next man uh okay let's
just say it man Rey phenomenal Rey is
girl Luke in this movie that's
diminishing it but she's our hero of
this arc was Luke Skywalker in the in
the first three movies the original
trilogy if you will but now clearly as
we've seen in the posters and the
marketing and as we saw on the movie
itself particularly by the end of that
movie this arc is all about race so she
is essentially again not diminishing and
bowing down but his girl Skywalker I'll
tell you right now I like girl Luke
better than boy Luke man girl Luke kicks
ass you know whiney she ain't talking
about no power converters and [ __ ] like
that takes care of herself she's in the
desert just like another little kid who
was left in the desert for their own
safety
can't believe I didn't see that until
the end of the movie in any event I love
that cheap you know Finn keeps trying to
save her and she
mine's up saving him he keeps grabbing
handshakes stop holding my hand stuff
like that really fun character excellent
performance by Daisy Ridley I've never
seen her before she now wants here and
everything's wonderful man um what else
do I got written down calm creepy kylo
Ren forces himself on Poe I was badass
man that scene the interrogation scene
just again how come Adam driver plays
that character i don't i don't watch
girls so I didn't know anything about
Adam driver so dude it's like a
discovery for me right now I mean I
liked his performance so much I'm like
maybe watching girls and stuff to talk
about Star Wars doesn't matter this guy
was great man like I loved how calm he
was it's tough all centered and just
smooth and and when he took off his
helmet he's like look at that hair
beautiful like Jon Snow type hair and
stuff and he did kind of resemble
spoilers a little bit Harrison Ford
since he's supposed to be playing
spoilers spoilers kylo Ren is the son of
Han Solo and Princess Leia were general
Leia Organa at this point so I like that
sequence with him and Poe and he's
pulling the information out of him and
Poe's fighting it and stuff and he just
steps out he's like the informations in
a droid we see great use of the force
man this is this movie I think more than
any of the other flicks has the most
impressive use of the force left and
right so JJ oh my god you crushed it
let's see man the TIE fighters in the
SunShot we've seen in the trailers but
like you know the this beautiful like a
kind of Apocalypse Now looking
helicopter shot with some but it's Thai
fighters and Sun like at one point in
our lives that just would have been some
cool t-shirt that you bought on a
website now it's in a movie man what a
great [ __ ] visual that was and that
leads to the reveal of Almighty valor in
the Falcons back we all know was going
back we saw in the trailer Howard came
back that was the magic moment that when
the reveal happens man woo everyone in
the audience whooped and I was delighted
I worked as well like that one
politician guy was like yeah yeah and it
just sounded weird everyone looked at me
and stuff loved it loved the dogfight
the chase watch and Ray Drive it that
the Millennium Falcon that watch and fin
fight from the guns using the guns that
had the same you know a little fervor
that Luke was using when he was
targeting [ __ ] like that I was a little
callback these tracks that was so damn
sweet but that hole
which just seeing that chip again think
about as one of the things that was
missing man am I gonna say that's the
heart of the movie but like big part may
be the spleen of the Star Wars movies is
the Millennium Falcon and it wasn't in
the prequels here we got it man we got
it in the UH
seeing it go to work was nuts that leads
to the introduction reintroduction of
two of our favorites from the Star Wars
trilogy of course I'm talking about Han
and Chewie we all knew they're in the
movie based on the trailer is real all
that stuff but what an upgrade I thought
they were ban Chewie
this is best Chewie I've ever seen in a
movie he gets to do a lot of stuff in
this movie and it gets to be funny to
like went on surface of the star killer
planet you know and it's all snowy and
he's like bands like you're cold laid
stuff like they's cold old man Chu he's
like you know a couple hundred years old
at this point
so that seeing them back on the ship
was phenomenal seeing them interact with
one another was phenomenal but you know
just having Han and Chewie back and
putting him into seeing the Bo caster
did the laser Bo caster which gets a lot
of play in the movie it never really did
in any of the other movies so much so
that Han gets to use it in this movie
and like makes a thing of it and stuff
and in some kind of way where he's never
thought to use the Bo caster before he's
just like I like this but I was happy to
see in pure impermanent comes into play
later on out bo caster just took a jump
into legendary status of Star Wars
weaponry because of this movie and
because of later on Chewie gets to use
it but you son of a [ __ ] we'll talk
about that in a second man
let's see Harrison Ford as Han Solo it's
like seeing your favorite uncle come to
your house and he's like hey let's go to
the mall and he buys your [ __ ] and you
know takes you to the movies r-rated
movies you know and buys your beer when
you're a teenager and stuff like that
he's like seeing drunkle you know han
Solo it was fantastic as usual loved him
like a warm family member he's welcome
back and he gets to play like he's the
elder statesman at this point man so
everything he says has like 30 years
worth of meaning behind it
it was wonderful for me to see seeing I
mean if we could talk about Han let's
talk about grandma dynamite man Leia
Princess Leia Organa general Leia Organa
seeing her in the movie just I was a
huge Princess Leia fan as a kid me I
want to marry when I grew up so seeing
her in the movie and and seeing hey that
would have been my future that's who I
would have been married to if everything
worked out the way that nine-year-old
cat wanted it to be I would've been very
happy that was my future what a stunning
woman she still is and in [ __ ] folk
control man I love seeing Leia again
controlling the resistance and I loved
seeing the reunion of course between her
and Han I was my favorite romance when I
was a kid man you know I love you I know
and stuff like that so watching those
two get together again for the first
time in years was that's where I first
got glassy I was like they love each
other oh it's good see and then they
start talking about their kid man and
they don't say his name they say our son
a lot and stuff but you should get the
idea
kylo Ren is their kid and he went bad he
had a little bit of backstory where Leia
says she shipped him off to Luke for
training because obviously he was
showing off powers of the force but you
know who knows what happened there he
went bad and so he became this dude and
and becoming Knights of Ren and changed
his name and is now working with Snoke
big CG effect guy who sits at a chair
and so played by Gollum so you know it's
it's it's epic kind of storytelling in
there man but the seeing it all begins
to seeing Han and Leia together again
realizing they had this relationship
that we didn't get to see between the
movies like I have to return the Jedi
and this movie presumably they had sex
because they got a kid and stuff so it
was nice seeing them together the hug
scene we've seen in the trail that shot
but that made me melt as like oh I hope
they live together happily forever and
we know what happens um okay
seeing a kid Kyle oh man han and Leia
talk about their prodigal son I said Han
says this line he's got too much Vader
in him and my I got goosebumps cuz I
don't know if Han Solo has ever said the
word Vader before he probably has
somewhere in the trilogy and I can't
remember it but hearing him say Vader
was like oh man like this weird it's a
weird acknowledgment where he's like
your father your father
Darth Vader man it was crazy but just
hearing him say the word I can I was
sitting there trying to remember when
did he ever say Darth Vader in the
original trilogy so even that was kind
of thrilling man and suddenly there's
family relation one of my favorite
moments Empire Strikes Back the doors
open and Han Solo taking shots at Darth
Vader and he just deflects him and stuff
like that so he didn't really ever talk
about Darth Vader I don't think I could
be wrong man so hearing him say he's got
a lot of Vader in him that I was like
yeah he sure does man geez kylo Ren by
the end of the movie he a lot more Vader
in a minute we'll talk about that in a
sec masks on Ted at the cantina bar
attack is that's the scene that I was on
set for man I touched that building that
they all went inside and I saw the
attack scene when the Empire shows up a
saw him shooting that that there's a
huge space man and it was crazy I could
I was right there
I was just off camera I could have
picked up a rock thrown it and I would
have been in the star war that will give
you I wanted to do that because that
could be next to somebody in theater and
be like you see that stormtrooper get by
a rock
I [ __ ] threw that rock I was on set I
threw that rock I didn't but I was on
that set touch that building everything
was tactile and real and stuff saw those
characters live so who's really cool
sequence to see all put together the
star killer base firing the weapon now
you know granted it's like whether it's
the sit the Empire or the first order
gotta get a new idea Man 3 third time
was not the charm no more Death Star's
for these cats man but what I loved was
when they fired up the weapon for the
first time and they did the blast across
the galaxy I mean I loved watching five
planets blow up because they're like
this is ain't your daddy's dead stars
the mega Death Star but I like the shot
of the one planet where they see the
beam coming down and can't do anything
what are you gonna do run your whole
plan is about to be destroyed I thought
that was kind of [ __ ] chilling you
know yes that happened in Star Wars but
we didn't see people on the planet you
know that that they blew up the Alderaan
Alderaan is peaceful plan and [ __ ] so it
was nice I've seen some people online
going there's a lot like Star Wars well
yes it should be a lot like Star Wars
you know that's what I think and I was
not disappointed by that but Empire
better not make a giant weapon planet
ever I mean not because I'll watch it
you make any movie with a Death Star and
I'm there but these guys learn like pick
something else man
all right let's see kylo Ren has a
temper tantrum I thought that was badass
man I thought it was kind of cool
Washington to like turn out lights at me
I just crushed [ __ ] because he was bad
so I'm all for that man I like emo kylo
Ren let's see Finn being in sanitation
like when they go to the planet the star
killer base and and Han Solo goes what
what were you what division were you in
they think they're shut down the shields
and he's like sanitation I didn't even
realize it I just thought it's a guy
it's funny but then on Twitter all day I
got a bunch of people going like as a
reference of Clark's dude like you know
the line where he's just like Randall
says you know you think a stormtrooper
knows how to install install a toilet
mein all they know is killing him white
uniforms I am put that together man if
that's the case could just be sanitation
just a joke but if that's the case life
just got meta weird ladies and gentlemen
because I spent most of my career
quoting Star Wars movies and now if that
is a reference Star Wars Star Wars kind
of quote me they make reference in my
flick ah-ah-ah but if it's even if it
ain't as a funny line sanitation man um
let's see uh seeing Han Solo in a hot
light coat again like the coat he wore
on Hoth where he's like general I got a
bounty on that I gotta get out of here I
got me on as that did it for me little
stuff like that where I'm like that
looks like his winter coat we haven't
seen Hoth fatigues and years man so I
was delighted by that some people like
you're simple-minded I am very
simple-minded so simple-minded that was
delighted by the appearance of a jacket
that looked like a jacket I loved when I
was a kid but never wore and only saw in
a movie sue me ah let's see
Finn getting up in captain phasma's face
I thought that was fine he's a lot of
good humor in the movie man and I mean
ice cream buy that like there's funny
funny stuff in the flag and that was a
really cool moment more so yeah up in
her face and when she's got held captive
uh snow and sand ladies and gentlemen
two elements that you need in any great
Star Wars movie they went to a sand
planet they went to a snow planet as
well there was also a tree planet like a
door and stuff so that's all the
familiar iconography of Star Wars was at
play some people online are going like
whoa what I just feels like I watch Star
Wars good yeah and that's what I liked
about it but was completely different
take different angle next generation
story man like I was four I was like
this fits well in the universe man
honestly like remember the scene where
artoo and bb-8 put up their projections
and bb-8 little piece is the missing
piece and the map to find Luke Skywalker
spoilers but I warned you early
JJ is bb-8 and he's that missing piece
man that was missing from the Star Wars
universe for so long was somebody who
loves the Star Wars universe man and
boom that piece fits in so nicely like
he does with this movie so let's see man
ha yelling been at spoilers at kylo Ren
to stop him was heartbreaking
that's where I got really glassy and
rolled it's here because I was like he
named his kid Ben him and Leia named
their kid Ben and at first I was like
why would Han Solo name is kid Ben but
man when you think about like it's not
like they were tight or anything like
that he was like old man superstition
nonsense but and in Leia she was like
general Kenobi you knew my dad back in
Clone Wars and stuff like that so it's
not like they would necessarily have oh
family affinity but Ben Kenobi's the one
that brought them all together
han Solo doesn't meet Princess Leia or
Luke's coward or without Ben Kenobi so I
thought that was a sweet honorific and
when he goes Ben and he says it like his
father I got real emotional and I knew
what was coming man like you know I've
dreaded it and I was hoping I was wrong
but oh my god I felt that it was coming
and I love that speech that of course
we're gonna talk about the big scene on
the bridge I love kylo taking off his
mask and saying like you know I'm
there's something I want to do but I'm
scared I can't do it blah blah blah and
he's like I'm gonna help you do it and
you're like um and don't get close to
and don't get close this dude he's a
he's a force choker number one plus got
himself a lightsaber and stuff and when
it happens I was heartbroken do does
absolutely heartbroken you know is like
watching your favorite uncle died of
cancer slowly or something like that or
your favorite uncle get killed by his
kid your cousin y'all are you shot of a
badge he was amazing so very emotional
stuff of course that's where I cried
watching Hansell
han Solo spoilers leave the Star Wars
universe killed by his own son and and
you know I got to tell you his trip to
the darkside is [ __ ] complete man
like you know I thought that was a cool
story element where he's just like in
order to make the final pass to where he
wants to go to the dark side he's got to
kill his father and he [ __ ] did man I
liked how I kept calling him han Solo
you know he wouldn't call him father and
he that [ __ ] like just separated him he
said kylo Ren said he'd killed you know
Ben guess solo I guess would be his last
name or Organa depending on which gay
name he took less him but I liked that
scene a lot and but I hated the result
but not hated it like [ __ ] there's
Beauvais I hated it because I was a guy
the way like you know mean [ __ ] hate
it when cool characters in movies ty
says the guy is the buddy since 1977 man
you know and we see clearly that in this
movie
kylo shoots first right into Hans guts
and stuff maybe even a spleen I don't
know so it was it was you know it was
tough to see but I'm looking at the
things here that I wrote down really
tough to see but think about it man like
Anakin Skywalker's journey to the dark
side involves slang younglings and in
some weird way this is worse you know I
mean to me it's way worse I know those
young wings but I knew Han Solo who's my
boys my truncal so it was heartbreaking
to watch that but it led to what was for
me the absolute highlight of the movie
and I love this movie and everything in
it but one of the absolute highlights
the movie if not the highlight was
[ __ ] Chewie reacting going apeshit
Manley sees his boy gets Ted's car and
he takes the crossbone [ __ ] shoots
kylo Ren I was screaming I was yes
that's good my kind of movie right there
I'll watch a whole movie about Chewie
[ __ ] hunting down kylo and I hope to
god they let him [ __ ] kill kylo Ren
because he killed his boy han Solo and
[ __ ] that would make up for chewing not
getting a medal at the end of Star Wars
you let him [ __ ] kill that kylo Ren
for killing on so that's his [ __ ] boy
I feel like if somebody killed Jake
I'd forgotten I'd shoot him with [ __ ]
laser crossbone [ __ ] like that oh I
loved that Beach so much in the movie I
was a yes that's the pathos of the Star
Wars universe and stuff and think about
it's been a long
since you either like it all that
remember on Hoth II did it when you know
they were closing the blast doors and he
thought Han Solo was going to be out in
the cold and stuff loved it that was
where I went
weepy and stuff that was very emotional
movie for me that led up of course to
Rey kicking kylo ren's ass man a
lightsaber fight the reveal of the true
Jedi this was thrilling to say the least
man we've seen girl Jedi's holding
lightsabers and the prequels and stuff
but this was the first girl on boy Jedi
fight you know to the max man is
something like my wife she's been
waiting 30 years to watch this man to
see a girl fight a boy
on the lightsaber fight and it didn't
disappoint she kicked so much ass Daisy
Ridley's Rey character like what was
awesome was watching her fight with that
stick and then when she finally embraced
the force like when she's captive and
the stormtrooper and she tries using
using the force on him just like you
know you will bring you'll let me out of
here he's like I'm doing [ __ ] for you
rebel scum and then she [ __ ] puts it
on hardcore she's like you will release
me and open the door oh I was a good but
her fighting kylo Ren and kicking his
ass he fight to the end of the cliff and
then Bam Bam maybe she fights back and
[ __ ] my boy up and [ __ ] I love that
because that's him getting closer and
closer to Darth Vader who he wants to be
so [ __ ] badly he's getting all [ __ ]
up he's gonna become more machine than
man just like his hero Ned
watching her beat his ass the cliff keep
them fart and stuff perfect cliffhanger
stuff man the study knew those ah he's
gonna live to fight another day and I
hate it but I love it so much because I
wanna see chewy choke the [ __ ] life
out it's piece of [ __ ] kylo Ren I hate
him so much but I love the character and
I love the work that the actor I Adam
drivers doing let's see man artoo and
bb-8 a little sequence very very cute
the droid c-3po talks about like a red
arm doesn't explain why or anything like
that but was good to see those cats
involved of course
ray and Chewie and the Falcon at the end
incredibly moving man I was like oh this
is neat it reminded me of like Chewie
and Leia in the Falcon when she heard
Luke and they went to pick him up in
Jedi and stuff so that of course leads
to the big reveal in a man if you've
ever been spoiled by this for here comes
the big
spoilers man obi-wan Skywalker ray goes
and finds Luke Skywalker and by that
point I don't even realize it I was like
because I thought kylo Ren and Ray were
brother and sister so I thought they
were both Han Solo unlike latest kids
the way they portray it it seems like
Rey is Luke Skywalker's kid man she is
the daughter of the last Jedi Knight all
questions without it that beautiful
scene quiet up on the mountaintop where
you reveal the obi-wan Skywalker and she
gives her father back his lightsabers if
to be like take your dick back dad
you'll [ __ ] these first two big [ __ ]
killed Han Solo [ __ ] him up with your
light dick I love that man his powerful
ending and father and daughter reunited
and then you're sitting there going of
course like I didn't realize until that
moment I was like oh my gosh that's
she's laid it to Luke man and we don't
know who her mother is so that's one of
those elements of like I want to see the
movie bad I wanna see the next one I
know I gotta wait a couple years but
who's their mom and it better not be
midi-chlorians I'll tell you that but
ain't gonna because JD will never let
that [ __ ] happen let me tell you
something JJ Abrams is such an amazing
job this movie I trust him with my life
I trust him with my wife if JJ was like
maps xB wife it was like oh my god
do it reboot her and me with with your
magic wand with your with your
lightsaber and stuff he did phenomenal
man he brought our childhood back to
life man I loved it I loved that so much
i sat in the worst conditions watching
it and I would have watched it again in
those same conditions man so there's so
much more to talk about those are the
initial thoughts that I wrote down and
almost a half an hour's worth man I'll
be talking about it on podcast for the
next few weeks and we'll be talking
about I'll be talking about this movie
for the rest of my life that's how much
I enjoyed it man JJ you did it I loved
you I loved you before I was I loved you
for regarding Henry brother but I love
you for this man you brought the magic
back you create a cinematic fountain
youth you created an experience goes
beyond just making a movie it's a pop
cultural phenomena my mom's going to see
Star Wars dude she doesn't go to movies
that often anymore I'm gonna go see it
with my kid I saw it with my wife
tonight last all this just now when I go
see it again
with my kid is a movie for everybody man
and like you could pick a quibble about
this that did [ __ ] it like this is the
movie we dreamed we would see one day
when they said hey there might be a new
star
movies there's a new Star Wars movie
ladies gentlemen and it is stunning so
there's my report from the Future Passed
keV I hand it back to you and past mark
barnard and may the force be with oh man
holy [ __ ] dude I mean I can't I don't
want to spoil it so I'm not gonna react
to what I said but boy did I enjoy
hearing it yeah I mean did you know the
Darth Vader was Luke's father again
boilers some we found out in the future
memories of us I can't imagine that
review wasn't just this I mean here's my
prediction I haven't seen it obviously
because it hasn't happened the this clip
of us reviewing the movie my prediction
is my review is just like mmhmm I'm
talking about that like really horrible
crash it really jiggling and [ __ ] people
like you guys got man tits good that's
my review is gonna be it's gonna be that
good your prediction my prediction is I
will be a little bit less effusive which
seems to be my speed I just got crap in
the mouth I really miss Goodin Oh Levi
we'll find some third act problem that I
will fix this Joe because he actually
listened to that part he's fun he's good
I'm the fix-it man like honestly
everybody in this town should be calling
you up and being like we're having a
third act probably won't do like XY and
Z Nick where's my check
bring it drop it in my bank account if
you want to he refused appraised you're
gonna hear from me let me tell you
something even if like they drop the
ball I ain't saying it too much I've
invested way too much loving this know
I've seen in a lot be honest with a lot
of people like you've seen the whole
thing I have not but I saw a lot of it
and the [ __ ] I saw had me weapon and by
now now I mean pulling out weapons I
mean like a ruin
I mean weeping I was just I was copious
tears I've seen [ __ ] that'll turn you
right tonight Lincoln and that means
something hmm so by now you're all in a
group lot people probably already saw
bone out I hope so and so did we
but not us you're not weird damn us
this is weird this is like trying to
follow what was that backwards movie
that Nolan did yeah memento yeah we are
having a crisis on Infinite Earths right
now yeah I love this man bring it finds
of reference to go out on man with that
crisis we're gonna get on the cosmic
treadmill get out of here or save all
your lives don't thank us or anything
like that from the fat caveman come back
next week see us here man I'm Kevin
Smith mark Barnard uh come see us next
week here in the fat cave same fad time
same bat-channel
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith getting
good
a man's meat Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder